Use code TV and get $50
off plus a free foot rest.
♪ ♪
>> Lawrence: WELCOME BACK.
THIS WEEK WE’VE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE NEVER ENDING CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE AND DEMOCRAT RUN
CITIES, PLACES LIKE CHICAGO LED
BY LIBERAL LORI LIGHTFOOT HAVE
ALREADY SEEN 474 HOMICIDES THIS
YEAR.
EVEN SMALL CITIES LIKE ALBANY,
GEORGIA, CAN’T ESCAPE THE
HORROR.
9-YEAR-OLD NIGEL BROWN WAS
MURDERED IN HIS BED THIS WEEKEND
DURING A DRIVE-BY SHOOTING.
BUT BRAVE RESIDENTS OF THE
CITIES AREN’T WAITING FOR THEIR
LEADERS TO STOP THE BLOODSHED.
AND ALL ALBANY CITY COMMISSIONER
RAISED $10,000 TO BRING THE
KILLER OF NIGEL BROWN TO
SERVICE.
JULISSA FORD IS OR WHO DON’T
LIKE LOOKING TO HONOR HER LATE
SON WHO WAS KILLED BY GUNFIRE
LAST YEAR AT ONLY NINE YEARS
OLD.
SHE IS WORKING TO COMBAT THE
CARNAGE IN HER CITY.
JALEN JOHNSON, JULISSA FORD
JOINED ME NOW.
MS. FORD, WE ARE SO SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS.
YOU TOOK THAT PAIN AND YOU
DIRECTED IT TOWARD HELPING THE
COMMUNITY.
WHAT MADE YOU DO THAT?
>> YES, MY SON WAS ALWAYS A
CHILD THAT WANTED TO GIVE BACK
TO HIS FRIENDS.
AND WANTED TO BE THAT HELPING
ONE.
AND TO LIVE OUT HIS LEGACY, I
STARTED JUST BEING MORE INVOLVED
WITH MY COMMISSION TEAM WITH
HELPING THE KIDS IN THE
COMMUNITY JUST HAVE A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY AND A SAFETY NET TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO GROW UP.
>> Lawrence: JAELYN, I WANT TO
GO TO YOU.
NIGEL BROWN WAS KILLED IN AN
DRIVE-BY SHOOTING IN THE BED
LIVING HIS LIFE.
YOU DECIDED TO STEP UP TO THE
PLATE, BECAUSE NO ONE WAS COMING
UP AND OFFERING SOLUTIONS OR
TRYING TO GET THE KILLER.
AND YOU DECIDED TO OFFER OF
REWARD.
WHAT HAS THE RESPONSE BEEN?
HAVE YOU GOTTEN TIPS IN?
WHAT ARE YOU SEEN ON THE GROUND?
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT, LAWRENCE.
I WOULD FIRST WANT TO SAY THAT I
AM PRAYING FOR NIGEL BROWN’S
FAMILY P OF THE INCIDENT
HAPPENED 9-YEAR-OLD NIGEL
BROWNED DOWN MIKEBROWN -- OUR LE
AT THE WHEEL.
I DECIDED TO DONATE $10,000 OF
MY OWN MONEY.
TO HELP BRING A SUSPECT FORWARD
PAIRED THIS SHOULD NOT HAPPEN TO
ANY MOTHER IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
KIDS SHOULD BE UNTOUCHABLE, AND
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO LIVE,
GROW, AND PLAY.
THEY’VE SEEN THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF, WAS ALSO RUNNING
FOR CITY COMMISSION IN ALBANY,
HAS BEEN ABLE TO STEP UP AND
OFFER TANGIBLE RESULTS TO THESE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY INSTEAD OF OFFERING
EMPTY SOLUTIONS.
I’M WILLING TO FIGHT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
>> Lawrence: JULISSA, I SEE
THE PICTURE OF YOUR SON.
I FORGOT TO ASK YOU, WHEN YOU
TALK TO THE LEADERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE, DO YOU GET ANY CLOSER
FROM THEM?
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THIS IS GOING
TO TAKE A TURN?
WHAT IS IT LIKE OUT THERE?
>> IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE I’M
FROM, IT’S DEVASTATING.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
COMMUNITY LEADERS OUT THERE, BUT
WE NEED MORE OF A VOICE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE DON’T HAVE THAT.
AND THAT IS WHY I’VE BEEN TRYING
TRYING TO ADVOCATE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY WITH GIVING A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR SAFETY.
BECAUSE WE DON’T HAVE ANY.
>> Lawrence: WHAT DOES THE ONE
JAR DEAL?
WHAT IS THAT FOUNDATION FOCUS
ON?
>> 1 JAR FOUNDATION IS A
NOT-FOR-PROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
I CREATED IN HONOR OF MY SON.
AND WHAT 1 JAR DOES IS JUST GIVE
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY AND
FOCUSING ON THE KIDS, THE
CHILDREN OF THE COMMUNITY, AND
THE YOUTH.
AND JUST GIVING THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE KIDS.
>> Lawrence: JAELYN, WHAT IS A
MESSAGE FOR THE LEADERS THAT ARE
OUT THERE?
YOU ARE A YOUNG MAN YOURSELF,
YOU ARE IN THE CAPITAL LIVING
YOUR DREAM.
YOU ARE FROM ALBANY AND YOU
DECIDED TO STEP UP AND RUN FOR
OFFICE IN YOUR TOWN.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE FOR THE
PEOPLE?
>> LOOK, I WORKED ON
CAPITOL HILL FOR A WONDERFUL
CONGRESS MEMBER.
AND I DECIDED TO MOVE BACK
PERMANENTLY TO MY HOMETOWN OF
ALBANY, GEORGIA, TO STEP UP TO
THE PLATE AND TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR MY FAMILY AND
ALSO THE RESIDENTS OF ALBANY,
GEORGIA, BECAUSE WE’VE ARTIE HAD
11 HOMICIDES THIS YEAR.
THAT IS INSANE.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO LIVE AND
GROW TOGETHER WITHOUT FEARING
FOR OUR LIVES.
I WANT TO TELL EVERY LEADER IN
MY HOMETOWN THAT IT’S TIME TO
STEP UP TO THE PLATE AND TAKE ON
THE CHALLENGE WE CAN PROTECT OUR
CITIZENS WITHOUT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
WE NEED TO COME TO THE TABLE
WITH TANGIBLE SOLUTIONS TO OFFER
OUR CITIZENS WHAT THEY DESERVE.
AND I’M WILLING TO DO THAT.
THAT IS THE REASON I CAME BACK
TO RUN.
>> Lawrence: THIS IS HAPPENING
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
JAELYN, JULISSA, A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT IT, BUT YOU GUYS ARE